hundreds of thousands of Nevada families
will be out of a lot of money in
emergency assistance when it comes to
buying groceries extra SNAP benefits
implemented during covid-19 will come to
an end in just a few months now
Victoria's on this story live in studio
to explain how this may impact and
affect your family
Brian and Kirsten since March of 2020
qualifying families on Snap were getting
two payments a month to give you a
better perspective of how much of that
extra money is being taken away from
families a senior who got 23 dollars a
month on Snap was also receiving a
payment of 258 dollars in the middle of
the month
and an adult with two kids was getting
eighty dollars in the beginning of the
month also getting 660 dollars mid-month
but now those second payments will be
coming to an end leaving families
wondering how they will afford groceries
it's hard living check to check a
grocery store Ron comes with a lot of
planning for Jennifer Harper my deep
freezers are empty and I'm not prepared
Harper has 10 people in her household
with seven kids she needs to feed she
would get two hundred dollars in monthly
SNAP benefits and with the emergency
payments she would get an extra 180
dollars we were able to stock up our
pantry we got a lot of canned goods rice
beans we stocked up on those
non-perishable items but after March
14th that second payment will end I'm
used to having this extra benefit I've
been kind of structuring my um
finances around it honestly when they
cut off the extra stamps it's going to
be like then we really can't even afford
meat at all so like my kids are going to
be eating Top Ramen every day all day
Harper is just one of more than 400 000
Nevada families that will lose the extra
payment resulting in food banks being
prepared for an uptick in need we are
just trying to make sure that we have
all the food that we need to make sure
that our community does not go hungry
and I'm a working professional I have to
go to food pantries to survive when
covid put the world at a pause in 2020
that is when the extra payment started
the issue is now three years later
prices for groceries aren't what they
used to be one dozen of eggs is just
enough for one breakfast like that's one
reference one day and that's like seven
dollars
Harper says now she will stock up as
much as she can until the extra benefits
end the Nevada Division of Welfare and
Supportive Services say they issued over
1 billion dollars in the emergency
benefits for families Brian